laissez-vous un pourboire quand vous
allez récupérer une commande dans un
restaurant est-ce que vous laisser un
pourboire à la caisse d'une chaîne de
restauration rapide
10 15 20 % quand vous régler un achat
avec une carte de débit ou de crédit la
machine vous offrent presque
automatiquement ce choix est le
consommateur lui a l'impression d'une
porte nécessairement avoir le choix on
va faire le point sur cette tendance
avec jacques nantel il est professeur
émérite en marketing à hec montréal en
somme si nantel bon jour même ces tenues
est ce que c'est une impression ou sait
bien qu alors que de plus en plus de
commerçants mettre cette option là de
pourboire automatique si on veut au
moment du paiement non ce n'est pas une
impression c'est s'est généralisé c'est
un peu comme un feu de forêt en ce
moment ça touche beaucoup de secteurs ça
touche évidemment la restauration sans
tain ça touche mais dans l'hôtellerie
mais ça touche dans certains cas les
concessionnaires automobiles pour les
réparations ça touche certains corps de
métiers comme les plombiers ça touche
les marchands en quincaillerie
bref tout le monde tout le monde vous
sollicite pour pour enfin
marquer la satisfaction que vous avez du
travail on aime on a l'impression par
contre que c'était moins répandue avant
que ça c'est multiplier dans les
derniers mois et peut-être même plus
lors de la pandémie est ce que c'est le
cas oui c'est exactement le cas en fait
la technologie pour le module de
paiement qui permet de mettre un
pourcentage ou un montant existe depuis
très longtemps j'existe facilement
depuis 2010 les premiers les premières
versions donc la technologie existait
avant la pandémie maintenant la pandémie
évidemment le accéléré parce que la
pandémie est pratiquement fait
disparaître le monétaire vous savez on
avait peur de tout allait bien on
préférait non seulement préféré mais on
nous imposait de taper sur le clavier en
fait de terminale avec notre carte pour
ne pas y toucher alors mesnac on est
passé pratiquement à 100% vers la
monnaie virtuelle mais pourquoi s'en
priver on au programme le terminal pour
que il vous sollicite pour donner un
pourboire oui mais ce qui dérange les
consommateurs passionnante elle sait que
cette pratique là sans racines de plus
en plus dans des commerces on n'avait
pas l'habitude de laisser des pourboires
où les commerces où le service est
minimale voire inexistant or le
pourboire on se dit c'est pour rémunérer
un service non qu'est ce que ça donne
comme impression consommateur
va écouter c'est ça donne deux
impression pendant la pandémie ça
donnait l'impression
non seulement qu'on aimait dire écoutez
je j'apprécie votre service j'apprécie
votre présence mais ça donnait aussi
beaucoup et on l'a sondé à travers
plusieurs sondages chez les jets
ça donne également la possibilité de
dire je veux
être partie prenante des problèmes que
vous avez alors c'est sûr qu'en
restauration en restauration rapide là
où on allait chercher une commande on
savait que les restaurateurs avaient de
la difficulté donc on était on était
heureux de leur donner un coup de mecs
de donner un coup de main à leurs
employés on n'est plus là aujourd'hui
dans tous les magasins sont ouverts et
lorsque c'est votre concessionnaire
automobile qui vous demande de taper sur
la machine et de rajouter 15 % à une
facture de 1500 dollars de réparations
là ça commence à être un peu jeune mais
est ce qu'on donne suffisamment le choix
au consommateur monsieur nantel quand on
voit sur la machine dont 15 18 des fois
ça va jusqu'à 20% est ce qu'on est ce
qu'on peut refuser est-ce qu'on peut
choisir un autre pourcentage où on sent
coupable et on n'y va pas ce sont deux
questions oui on peut refuser absolument
mais on se sent coupable et les
programmations sont fait un peu en sorte
que font encore pardon que l'on vous
fasse ça vous sentir coupable c'est
encore plus prévalents soit en passant
au québec et est du km dans le code
québec que j'avais écrit avec mon ami
jean marc léger entre autres qu'on
mettait le doigt là tu dis vous savez
les consommateurs québécois et
québécoises des tests déplaire on est
gêné de déplaire littéralement dont
avait d'ailleurs même sondé la
propension à donner un pourboire et on
une proportion plus élevée a donné un
pourboire que dans le reste du canada
souvent par contre des pourboires
peuvent être plus bas mais on est gêné
de ne pas donné pour bois c'est sûr que
si on vous sollicite pour des 1 15 20 ou
22 pour ça ben vous allez prendre nos
plus petit commun dénominateur qu'il 15
pour ça mais vous allez donner ça c'est
sûr mais quel est l'objectif là des
commerçants avec ce sont des montants
qui reviennent aux employés quand même
bon et là on vante l'on rentre dans une
zone qui est extrêmement grise c'est sûr
que l'objectif c'est de permettre aux
employés d'avoir un salaire qui est
majorée et on sait à quel point c'est
important lorsqu'on est en pénurie de
main d'oeuvre comme c'est le cas
actuellement de sorte que les employeurs
permettent la chose maintenant je vous
dirais que à bien des égards les
employeurs devraient peut-être faire un
examen de conscience parce que le
problème il est peut-être pas du côté
des pourboires que du côté de la
possibilité de rémunérer correctement si
les employeurs s'assoyait köhler un peu
en direct et voix les séparent des
pourboires puis on va majorer votre
salaire de 7 minutes pour ça je
comprends que ce serait pas
nécessairement profitable mais ce serait
peut-être au moins plus transparent
parce que lorsque vous allez dans un
magasin où on vous dit chez nous ça
coûte 1 et que après vous êtes plus que
ceux listés à donner à 15% par dessus
les taxes qui elles sont déjà acquises
pour ça ça commence à coûter cher mais
tu touches à evian engendre une
initiation avec un sentiment de
culpabilité par dessus tout vous
remercie vous connaissez un appel aux
explications sont toujours appréciés
toujours plaisir merci et bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh